let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
gabe it looks like uh holy actual [ __ ]
we have some really big breaking news
[Music]
it looks as if the
the fbi has raided
the home of the former guy the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa
himself donald trump they have raided
mar-a-lago and we are getting
confirmation right now from donald trump
itself this is from his true social page
this is an actual real an actual
statement okay actual statement i didn't
make this was it right it is well who
would do that sort of thing but here's
what i want to say is i do i don't
believe that daniel dale has
confirmed this but i just pulled it from
true social this is a statement from
august 8 2022
from the former guy the cheeto dust
mobster grapple poop in poopy pants
himself donald j trump he says these are
dark times for our nation
as my beautiful home mar-a-lago in palm
beach florida is currently under siege
raided and occupied by a large group of
fbi agents gabe it looks like we finally
made it to the final round of [ __ ]
around and find out
oh there we are here we are it looks
like the fbi is raiding mar-a-lago um
we're gonna go to a few statements here
and see um how the uh media is reacting
specifically maybe
i am i am like briefly scanning through
this docker right now we've got the
radical left democrats we got
uh what do we got third world countries
thrown in there like that okay uh what
else we got
all the great work
we got in awoken there we got russia
russia russia impeachment hoax number
two
number one
let's keep in mind that he was impeached
twice okay
uh wow yeah he's he's really throwing
everything and seeing what sticks well
yeah he's throwing the ketchup at the
wall and seeing these statements will
stick here gabe wait did he mention
hillary he mentioned hillary absolutely
he mentions hillary clinton he also says
here if you look he says they even broke
into my safe it looks like that's gonna
be something that's trending that they
broke into his safe see that's what
happens dude when you break laws and you
crime and stuff and they come to raid
your house they really want to know what
you're hiding in the safe yeah the place
that they want and to look now you
mentioned watergate in here i mean i do
want i i do want to point out that 40
48 years ago to the day
is when richard nixon resigned or
announced that he was resigning as
president wait wait august 8th august
8th 1974 richard nixon announces he's
resigning as president
august 8 2022
president trump announces that he's
being raided by the fbi so
coincidence
uh well there might not be any in this
day and age uh let's go to jesse waters
and fox news he's got on uh the the the
uh
oh boy uh boing boing himself dan
bongino is going to react to the news
here of their mussolini jesus being
raided by the fbi because he's a
criminal let's find out what old jesse
waters and boing mine has to say here
i just want to say in closing
listen america they're laughing at you
the left thinks this is hilarious if you
doubt me just go to any of their goofy
platforms twitter elsewhere right now
they think this
is hilarious
we sure as hell do i don't normally
agree with this guy gabe but let me tell
you something he is spot on this is
[ __ ] hilarious that they did not
isn't he on isn't he is he on twitter i
forget or was he banned from the goofy
side twitter no i don't i don't know
where exactly his b he's been banned
from he's been banned between his ears
he does not have a brain here and anyone
who could not see this cup not see this
coming is absolutely out of there
especially after a weekend like cpac man
they were very pro pro nazi and not only
that but then we found out that trump
also wanted to find out how to make his
military his generals more like those of
hitler right
now this morning yeah
this is this whole weekend kind of
raveled up into nazi
you know nuremberg rally propaganda
and then we now get this moment at the
end of the day where it's like oh
their hitler gets raided
his speaker gets raided speaking of
nazis i got the old vampire stephen
miller here
let's see what his reaction is to his
orange mussolini jesus
being raided by the fbi
this is an abomination
you have the sitting president of the
united states joe biden
through his justice department through
his fbi does he sound familiar he
he sounds like he's kind of like uh
donald he's he sounds like you know he
sounds like he sounds like uh like mark
uh mark zuckerberg whenever mark
zuckerberg is like on if anyone wants to
go back onto google or and
find past conferences where mark
zuckerberg talks he's like let me tell
you about facebook facebook and the
internet it's a it's a collective uh
consciousness we're all trying to
connect and and get close to each other
on facebook why are we talking about
twitter it's an abomination it's
abomination you know what you know what
it probably is it's probably that
zuckerberg and stephen miller are the
same alien they're just wearing a
different skin suit
that probably is what it is let's finish
what this skin suit version has to say
conducting a raid on the person who is
presumed to be
his opponent
in the next election then his sense horn
in the next the next election is 2022
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
what is he talking about the next
election joe biden hasn't announced he's
running in 2022 and neither has donald
trump there is no presidential election
in 2022. you cannot you cannot be
running against you cannot have a
contender a competitor you have no one
if neither party has announced their key
candidate
then neither
is running then neither of them can be
the opposing
candidate for against each other so like
i don't understand it i don't understand
well i mean it is them projecting they
want joe biden to run they want donald
trump to want uh to to win uh run so
well i mean i would i would love to
watch dark brandon kick the cheeto dust
mobster's ass to tell you an honest
truth but let's finish what the the old
skin suit the vampire skin suit has to
say here
and also the 45th president of the
united states as president trump pointed
out in his statement
it is
riseable
that this would be proportion riseable
right what what what what is he trying
is he trying to get people to do
something right now is i don't know i
don't know if he's talking about boners
or he's talking about civil war action i
don't i'm gonna go with the latter of
the two that makes sense i don't know he
could be talking about the former but i
feel like he's talking about the latter
like if you're gonna rise up but the
other thing that i found really
interesting or not interesting but just
like the key point he goes in there he
said biden's
fbi biden's department of justice
who hired who is the head of the fbi and
who hired them tony well you know there
is there was that guy named james comey
but there was a president who was really
corrupt and he fired him to stop the
investigation into russia and i think he
hired i think his name was christopher
wray who was that guy who was that guy
who was president at the time i can't
remember oh
yeah well you know corruption runs deep
in the state of florida and let's see
what his uh
his fellow floor
is rubio at like a is he staying at
margalonga i don't know this may be one
of those cocaine's fueled sex orgy's
kind of private rooms or something i'm
not sure what this is this is really
[ __ ] weird his lighting's off um he
looks like he's being held hostage maybe
someone is forcing him to do this video
i have no idea
it wouldn't surprise me they forced
marco rubio to do a lot of things but
let's see what they forced him to say in
this video you know we've had divisive
politics and even anger in our politics
for as long as this country's existed
sometimes worse than others it's always
been there yeah the one thing we've
never had is there's never been a
country where people who take power like
becoming president now use that power to
persecute their past or future political
opponents we've never seen that
wait what
he's talking about the guy who ran on
the phrase lock her up right right yeah
i mean during a debate he's like well
you'd be in jail and i'm gonna put you
in jail like that kind of that kind of
stuff get the [ __ ] out of here yeah well
i mean again it's a republican party
projecting their own
their own desires their own kind of the
things that they said out loud right
they they're like if i'm in power i'm
gonna lock you up if i get this you know
this administration becomes mine then
what i will do is i will take my
personal vendetta against you
use all of my power
to do something that is a personal
attack because i don't like you
well you know another take i really want
to get here another take i really that i
was looking forward to all night long
is tucker carlson who who is on the
camera with tucker carlson when you need
him let's go let's go to tucker carlson
tonight and see what tucker has to say
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i am will kane in for
tucker
i guess tucker's not available tonight
what a [ __ ] can't even show up to his
own show
when his you would you would think of
all nice uh the guy who is you know
front and center propaganda for trump
and everything that is magga and putin
he would you would think he would he
would want to be there what is he doing
he'd stay where did he
he'd stand up for his buddy he'd stand
up well let's go to some other fox news
host and see exactly what they have to
say here is laura i'm not a nazi
ingraham joining me now is ohio
congressman jim jordan ranking member of
the house judiciary committee harmee
dillon chairwoman of the republican
national lawyers association as well as
victor davis hanson hoover institution
senior fellow congressman jordan let's
start with you ah that's enough that's
enough we don't need to uh we don't need
to go and dance that's enough of that
that's enough of that okay let's
you know i i can't imagine anyone like
you know we need to get a really really
unbiased opinion on this show and make
sure we really figure out what's going
on down there at mar-a-lago who should
we bring in did they spin a [ __ ]
wheel and then jim jordan popped up what
i mean i think i think they were like is
anyone available tonight and then jim
jordan finds like i'll go i'll do it
i'll come on the show and they're like
fine you can come on the show
well i gotta i got a clip here from new
york city uh this is a reaction directly
from the former guy himself uh looks
like he's going to
maybe respond to what the raid was let's
listen in
mr trump can we get your reaction to the
raid
mr trump
[Music]
no no no he's not no comment no comment
no comment no comment whatsoever you
know the best part about this game is he
was actually in new york city when this
happened so when the raid's going on the
fbi's rummaging through his ship oh he's
hearing it
yeah he's hearing it from another party
and ranked that's right it's um it's
very interesting once
they went into my safe they took my
stuff i just wanna i would i i kind of
would love to be a fly on the wall to
one understand when they opened that
safe what did they pull out
and then also the person that had to
relay that information to trump and be
like
listen sir uh
they came in it was a large group of
well probably they were like it's like a
few agents maybe i don't know or or
there could have been a whole team i'm
not sure i mean somebody told me and i
don't know if this is true somebody said
there's 46 bathrooms in mar-a-lago and i
don't know if that's true
so you think they took every one of the
toilets then i think they might have i
mean that's a lot of plumbing they got
to get the paper out
all the plumbing to get all those notes
about it so that might mean a lot of
hands so there could have been a large
group of fbi agents i think there's
probably a lot a lot of evidence about
elise stefanik and why she's still on
trump's side um here's another clip from
laura ingraham tonight let's see what
the nazi has to say they're supposedly
so worried about threats to democracy
they want to short circuit democracy by
taking someone off the field that's it
to just people watching this tonight
that's what it looks like so while they
grandstand about democracy and
preserving democracy what's this
this is not what we expect from um okay
these are the same stupid same stupid
[ __ ] who want to make sure that
hunter biden is prosecuted for something
who god knows what so that joe biden
can't be prison anymore they want to
they wanted to lock hillary clinton up
for her [ __ ] emails for years and
years they still want to lock her up for
these emails
that way they can't they can take her
off the field and they're going to
complain about an attorney general who
is appointed by a president who is
actually elected by the the actual
majority of the people the popular vote
and he selects an attorney general not
only that the majority of the people in
the country have been calling for that
attorney general too [ __ ] something
he finally does something they're like
oh
you just don't like to i mean here these
people have been right well they're like
you got to take the player off the field
well here's the thing trump hasn't
announced so he's not actually a player
on the field again neither is biden
but it's their fear of this woke left
democratic state you know key word
democratic but whatever well you know
they're always afraid of things you
remember in 2020 they were like oh the
democrats are gonna defund the police
lawn we need to be the party of law and
order and we need to be we have the rule
of law we can't defund the plea like
they went on and on and on
and there really wasn't a democrat out
there saying this [ __ ] but tonight on
the other hand tonight
there's a lot of these [ __ ]
chuckleheads who have changed their
minds because apparently marjorie taylor
green wants to defund the police isn't
this um
just rich she fund the fbi when it's
well one when it's convenient for them
they say no no no we don't believe we
don't trust we don't want to put our our
our faith in law and order because
that's what this is saying right deep on
the fbi they've all of a sudden like
went far left this is the accidental
like
became a leftist moment where they're
saying defund the fbi and really what
they're saying is they don't like law
and order
when it comes to them right when the law
and the order
makes them on the receiving end right it
really feels like to me though marjorie
taylor green's like please defund them
before they come to my house exactly
yeah yeah please please defund them
before they come
to my house i don't i don't want dark
brandon to come for me because really
honestly this is this is the real news
here is that the doj has finally moved
on donald trump which is significant now
some people are speculating that this
has to do with the 15 boxes of of
classified documents that he had um some
are saying maybe not i mean there's a
lot of speculation out here but here's
the thing is we won't really know until
we get more of a tick tock of why this
raid is the way it is and it'll probably
be months down the line but i do want to
point out which is very significant that
this could be from information that they
did find inside those documents or it
could be other electronic devices or
documents that they have found recently
that would indicate that there was more
records at mar-a-lago uh we've had
eastmans we've had jeffrey clark we have
ruby giuliani all those all those and
remember the january 6 they were they
weren't allowed to get the documents
that were in those 15 boxes from the
national archives team right they were
rejected the doj and them they were like
no we can't give it to you which i think
was very ancient at the time because i
was like oh well if you've recovered the
things that you believed to have been
taken especially especially if it was
intentional then you would probably want
to use that in your case against donald
trump having something where he had
malicious intent
but if we're now finding that
potentially not everything was returned
or there were additional things that
they didn't know were missing
because somebody also keep in mind that
somebody told them about this safe right
they said there's something in the safe
or go check out the safe you want or
they have evidence that there is now
when the fbi does a raid i'm sure they
do a pretty good combing of right of
whatever said property is now at
mar-a-lago from what i understand
there's the residents part of the
property and there's other parts of the
property so it's still unclear we still
don't have the news of exactly how much
stuff they took they didn't take a lot
of [ __ ] though because i know he's got a
lot of tacky [ __ ] that they could take
oh yeah just in the room where he takes
the photos there's there's all those
things and all that [ __ ]
right and there's big stacks of [ __ ]
stupid papers laying around half of them
are blank because you know he's he's a
fraud he's a phony and that's where
we're at really is this this is the find
out phase of the [ __ ] around saga and
this is what happens gabe
when you [ __ ]
with dark brandon and i'll leave it at
that
it doesn't feel pain a remorse or fear
and it absolutely will not stop
[Music]
to all those of you who voted for
president trump there's no way out
[Music]
and gabe i'll leave it with that i'll
leave it with dart brandon folks this
has been breaking news donald trump has
been raided by the fbi at mar-a-lago
this is significant this is
groundbreaking please please absolutely
do not forget to subscribe right here on
the mind as touch network hit that
subscribe button stay up with this news
and any other news that comes your way
in politics with the january 6 select
committee all the work and all the
things that democrats are doing but we
stay on top of the gqp and the
republicans their antics and their
crimes so don't forget to subscribe
right here at the midas touch network
gabe thanks a lot for joining us for the
breaking news and everybody have a great
night the biggest criminal to ever enter
our white house takes the fifth
amendment in his civil trial not
surprising at all i wasn't surprised
were you surprised if you were surprised
boy you are not paying attention you
know it's really funny because the last
few days
we've had on and on and on the media is
really trying to make this out to be a
great thing for them to get ratings
around donald trump here when they're
saying oh what are the ramifications for
this it seems like it seems like this is
big government and everyone is
forgetting
that in new york that he was gonna he
did a deposition today and he pled the
fifth so he doesn't self-incriminate
himself the reason why he would do this
is because his business the trump
organization his family business that
he's ran for decades is charged with
crimes we keep forgetting this his cfo
his partner in his business and his
business itself is charged with crimes
he's a [ __ ] criminal why is it so
unprecedented that a [ __ ] criminal a
career criminal who is whose business is
charged with crimes in the state of new
york and his cfo alan weisselberg is
also charged with crimes in the state of
new york tisch james deposed him and he
pled the fifth so he dealt didn't
self-incriminate this morning i mean it
would be almost like someone who ran for
president and back in 2016 would say
only mobsters take the fifth
when you have
your staff
taking the fifth amendment
taking the fifth
so they're not prosecuted i think it's
disgraceful if you're not guilty of a
crime what do you need immunity for
pleading the fifth amendment pleading
the fifth amendment taking the fifth
amendment the fifth amendment in the
fifth amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment fifth amendment horrible you
see the mob takes of him if you're
innocent why are you taking the fifth
amendment have you ever seen anything so
corrupt
in your life have you ever seen a
greater embarrassment to our country
fifth amendment
bob
we gotta see this idiot say these things
that and then he does them it's all
projection always every [ __ ] time but
why is the media so surprised and it's
so unprecedented and right wingers are
so upset that the fbi would go raid his
home at mar-a-lago this is not
surprising it's not unprecedented it's
not it's unprecedented that you [ __ ]
morons still support this idiot you
[ __ ] morons put this bonehead in
office and then act like he was the
greatest thing since sliced bread after
one impeachment after two impeachments
after he [ __ ] incited a violent
insurrection and tried to take away our
government and our democracy this is not
unprecedented this is [ __ ] when
someone tells that tell them to [ __ ] off
it is not unprecedented that we in this
country treat a [ __ ] career criminal
like a career criminal that is something
we should continue to do and we need
more of it you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ]
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking